hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba
Jonah's me we are going to watch today a
video that came out a few weeks ago
called doctor disrespect black on black
berry by G fuel I don't know what we're
about to watch on our patreon we do
weekly Q&A as the TV show reactions is
the main drive of the patron page but
one of our top reward tiers is whatever
video you request we must definitely
cover and put on the youtubes and it's
always a request that I'm like are we
getting into right never know exactly
more about to watch rarely do i watch
something where i'm like that's one of
these and it comes today from Tyler
Hague Tyler hey good man from Wisconsin
who every time we've talked with him he
always has like 82 monitors going on
greens 1 on what porn 1 with you know
important different porn and one with
like actual violence from the dark web
and then he has photos of his mom just
you know it's like a screensaver just
keeps switching in and out I wears these
special glasses to keep us all the way
open like the whole day yeah he never
blinks he's really kind guy though
really charming you think you know yeah
certified sociopath I hope you get to
meet him one day whoever you are that
lucky lady people do our patreon to get
awesome complimentary no an all honesty
this guy has the most contagious smile
you'll ever see smiles you're like oh I
can't stay on your lap that's just how I
feel any smiles I was thinking like if
Santa needed to step down I would feel
so warm inside if Tyler hag was
delivering presents every year but
that's just me okay see you've noticed a
few trophies
[Music]
even become just an EQ time video game
champion do you
[Music]
ha
[Music]
ddr yes
[Music]
tarji
don't cut don't cut please don't cut the
camera booyah
what if we actually did that their
fencing like awesome after-effects yeah
it looked pretty convincing
[Music]
everything must have had a budget
[Music]
a satyr
you want to be a champion like me by
doctor disrespect wait is this an actual
commercial product I guess is GG fuel
must be a real protein I mean if we're
like a energy supplement or something
here's what I know I want to see a
full-length movie of this guy huh yeah I
thought it was just some a YouTube video
we're watching I didn't realize like oh
we're watching an actual commercial an
energy formula okay all right I always
appreciate when people get wacky and
wild with their advertising I might have
to try this sometime that sounds like a
good time yeah I'd like to work out so
yeah maybe I'll buy some G fuel back to
my main point I want to see a
full-length movie of this guy I already
know what the movie would be it has like
that 80s style theme he's a champion and
then one day he meets his match act 2 he
thinks he's gonna win boom gets his ass
defeated so you have to go in there and
find that spark we all go back to basics
become humbled again and then realize
that all this was about the emotional
journey so he could become a better
person maybe even falls in love along
the way yeah and then beats the bad guy
B of the villain of the movie but
doesn't kill him it's like you know they
have respect for each other by the end I
Peter straight
god damn it do I respect you and the
sequel they team up to go against
someone else that would be great that
would be cool and then a third one you
introduced Andy Samberg from hot rod and
boom you got yourself a little cinematic
universe is what I'm talking about
imagine the 80s punch dancing montage in
that movie yeah is doctor disrespect an
actual character because I'm seeing this
other thing here called doctor
disrespect reacts to doctor disrespect
costumes it's gotta be I got to know
more about doctor disrespect now is this
Yes Doctor disrespect is like a product
of G fuel or is this some kind of
crossover promotional thing I mean from
what I can find
doctor disrespect has a channel that
average is every video he puts up in the
hundreds of thousands of view range and
yet you can't see what his subscribe
cabinets maybe we could become his first
who is this guy I'm in love I'm very
much in trade I want to know exactly who
he is right now this feels like a
character that like Joestar could be
yeah you know I don't know for whatever
reason that was the main thing I kept
thinking of during that video was like
just I could see Joe starving just like
this but seriously this guy needs like
an r-rated movie as soon as possible
mm-hmm it's r-rated comedy yeah like
macGruber but but better than macGruber
macGruber is pretty good it's pretty I
mean it's only the second best SNL movie
yeah that was good well thanks Tyler for
hit use against the doctor disrespect
yeah that let down a wormhole of a bunch
of questions wait a minute is this a
real commercial wait a minute
his doctor disrespect a real ongoing
character wait a minute it's doctor
disrespect have a youtube channel this
game is this man but yeah I love that
thanks for introducing us buddy thanks
for expanding our horizons alright well
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation and click that notification bell
and we'll talk with you soon